je le précise bien moi je suis contre
toutes les adhctions donc j'apparais
plutôt comme un répressif mais quand une
politique de prohibition donne des
résultats aussi inverse à toute
politique de prohibition qui a eu lieu
dans l'histoire qu'elle soit celle de
l'alcool ou les autres nous avons un
souci quant à la cohérence de la
politique un une politique de
prohibition ça se traduit par une
raréfaction du produit une baisse de la
qualité et une augmentation du prix en
France nous avons exactement l'inverse
une augmentation de la qualité une
augmentation de la quantité et une
baisse des prix il y a quand même un
sujet et quand une politique de
prohibition aboutit à l'effet économique
exactement inverse à celui rechercher
c'est donc que la politique est mauvaise
ou qu'elle est mal appliquée en France
c'est les deux la politique est mauvaise
parce qu'elle est incohérente et elle
est mal appliquée parce que bien
évidemment avec le nombre de
consommateurs que nous avons le nombre
de consommateurs réguliers que nous
avons le nombre de jeunes consommateurs
que nous avons et le changement de la
nature des produits par une augmentation
massive du taux de THC euh dans les
produits de type cannabisoïde l'arrivée
de produits de synthèse dont certains
sont
extraordinairement dangereux nitazè
quettamine et autres produits de
fabrication de dans son arrière cuisine
ou dans son labo la capacité désormais à
avoir des relations directes du
producteur au consommateur par la
surmultiplication des champs de
production ou des petits labos chimiques
à
petit petite zone de chalandise le
développement massif de la consommation
dans des zones qui sont passés de la
banlieu à l'aglo et de l'aglo à la
petite ou à la moyenne ville tous ces
éléments là accumulés montrent que la
politique s'il y en avait une de lutte
contre les stupéfiants est un échec
conceptuel structurel et opérationnel
donc il y a un souci générique qui
nécessite de reprendre le problème
depuis le début un qui consomme de
pourquoi on consomme trois comment on
consomme qu'est-ce qu'on consomme et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
reprendre la problématique d'abord
médicale qui est paradoxalement la plus
simple par la désaddiction y compris par
des mesures fermes de des addictions
jusqu'à la politique de lutte contre les
grands trafiquants et notamment sur un
certain nombre
d'espaces qui nous sont proches et qui
sont des paradis fiscaux ou des
blanchisseuses bien connu des produits
stupéfiants y compris des endroit où on
rrouve beaucoup
d'influenceurs qui ont basé leur leur
arrière-cours